- Yeah, I hate to tell you,
but you are wrong about the Constitution.
(stamp thumping)
It's not your fault,
I mean, that thing is
like seven pages long.
Who has time to read that?
And there's like two
dozen amendments, pff.
But it's not your fault,
everyone is wrong about the Constitution.
Think about this phrase,
(air whooshing)
from each according
to his ability,
to each according to his needs.
In 1987, the Hearst
Corporation conducted a survey
to mark the bicentennial
of the US Constitution.
Over 50% of survey participants
thought that that phrase
from each according to his ability,
to each according to his needs,
was part of the US Constitution.
And this wasn't a one-off result.
According to a 2002
Columbia Law School study,
nearly two thirds of persons polled,
thought that this phrase
came from the Constitution
or from one of the founding fathers.
But this phrase does not
appear in the Constitution.
James Madison, the author
of the Constitution,
didn't say it either.
So who did?
Well, this was written
by none other than Karl Marx in 1875,
and then parodied by George
Orwell in "Animal Farm".
Marx wasn't the first person
to articulate this idea.
Scholars traced the concept
to the New Testament,
which states, in part,
and distribution was made unto every man,
according as he had need.
Now, the Soviet Union eventually
incorporated the slogan
into it's Constitution as, quote,
"From each according to his ability,
"to each according to his work."
But that has never appeared
in the US Constitution.
So you can imagine if Americans
confuse the US Constitution
with the Soviet Constitution,
they're probably wrong about
a whole bunch of other things.
Let's talk about it.
One thing that people
get wrong all the time
is thinking that the Constitution mandates
(air whooshing)
that English
is the official language
of the United States.
That same 1987 Hearst
survey found that 64%
of the people believed
that the Constitution
made English the official
national language of America.
But English as the official language
has never been part of the Constitution.
Although, English was
the dominant language
at the time the Constitution was ratified,
many other languages flourished as well.
The most common languages
included Dutch, French, German,
and the many languages
spoken by Native Americans.
Enslaved people spoke African languages
as well as made their own
English based Creole languages.
And most of the founding fathers
favored bilingual education.
Thomas Jefferson spoke English,
(air whooshing)
French, Italian, Latin
and he could also read Greek and Spanish.
He hoped that America
would establish colleges
that would teach in
French, Spanish, German,
and other languages.
Others, like Ben Franklin,
saw it differently,
and said things
that were incredibly
offensive and Malthusian,
(air whooshing)
saying, quote, "Those
Germans who come hither
"are generally the most ignorant,
"stupid sort of their own nation.
"They will soon outnumber us,
"that all the advantages we
have will not, in my opinion,
"be able to preserve our language
"and even our government
will become precarious."
Luckily, he didn't win
the day on that one.
Now, states with large German populations
disagreed with Ben Franklin,
at least initially.
In the 1800s,
Pennsylvania and Ohio
passed laws allowing German
to be taught in public schools.
Of course, however, Americans
have consistently attempted
to limit the speaking of other
languages in this country.
Politicians have tried
to introduce Constitutional amendment
making English the official language,
which would force the government
to stop providing bilingual services.
So far, these efforts have failed.
And while a Constitutional
amendment hasn't passed,
Congress historically has
passed all kinds of laws
that would prevent people
from speaking non-English languages.
For example, in the 19th century,
the government forced
Native American children
to attend missionary schools.
In 1887, the Bureau of
Indian Affairs decided
that mission schools on
reservations were required
to provide all instruction in English.
Children who used their
own languages were bullied
and beaten by the instructors.
This, of course, led to
immense language loss.
And, of course, French
was the dominant language
in the Louisiana territory
for over 100 years.
The first Louisiana
Constitutions made English
and French the official
dual languages of the state.
But Louisiana was a melting
pot for different ethnic groups
and eventually their dialects merged
to produce what we call Louisiana French.
But in 1921,
(air whooshing)
Louisiana adopted a
new state Constitution,
which reversed the policy
of bilingual rights.
The state banned the teaching
of French in all public schools,
(air whooshing)
which highlights one
of the differences between
the US Federal Constitution
and individual state constitutions.
But of course, these trends
continue to this day.
Representative Louie Gohmert
introduced the English
Language Unity Act of 2021,
which would declare English as the,
(air whooshing)
quote, "Official language
"of the United States,
"to establish a uniform
English language rule
"for naturalization,
"and to avoid misconstructions
of the English language texts
"of the laws of the United States,
"pursuant to Congress's power
"to provide for the general
welfare of the United States,
"and to establish uniform
rule of naturalization
"under article one, section
eight of the Constitution."
Of course, the reason that
Gohmert wanted to pass this law
is because it's not in
the Constitution at all.
And Gohmert's bill was referred
to committee where it died.
But putting language aside,
surely that old chestnut,
(air whooshing)
no taxation without representation,
found it's way into the
Constitution, right?
Well, the popular history
of the American revolution
goes something like this.
The colonists got so fed up
with King George the third's high taxes
that they chucked British
tea into the Boston Harbor,
decided Americans would hence
forth become coffee drinkers,
and wrote a Constitution ensuring
that no one would ever be taxed again,
without being adequately represented.
(record scratching)
Well, as a resident
of the district of Columbia,
I would have to take issue
with this particular summary
of American history.
In the 1700s, the colonists
objected to the Stamp Act
and other similar laws
that imposed taxes on them,
because they couldn't vote
and didn't have
representation in parliament.
And in response, the English
came up with a theory
of virtual representation,
which meant that since parliament existed,
every British subject was represented,
regardless of whether they could vote.
Of course, the young American colonists
didn't exactly take to this
early version of Zoom meetings.
After all the pontificating
about taxes and voting
and the subsequent War of Independence,
perhaps the biggest surprise of all
is that the taxation
without representation
(air whooshing)
(coins clinking)
didn't make it
into the final cut of the Constitution,
though the colonists
didn't try hard to work it
into the founding documents.
The Articles of Confederation,
incorporated a we hate taxes stance
by denying the federal
government the right
to levy taxes at all.
This sounded cool on paper,
but was a really big mess in reality,
because the new government
couldn't pay it's war debts.
(air whooshing)
It also couldn't raise enough
money for an army or navy.
(air whooshing)
The British occupied
forts in the great lakes,
while also dumping it's
convicts into the colonies.
And so, for this and many other reasons,
the Americans had to write
a new governing document,
that eventually became the Constitution.
And you had better well believe
that it gave the federal
government the right to levy taxes.
The problem is they forgot to mention
that in order to levy taxes,
everyone needed to be
adequately represented.
The state and local authorities
also got the power to levy taxes,
but the end result
is that the Constitution
doesn't guarantee no taxation
without representation.
But the motto was still a rallying cry
for the disenfranchised populations,
especially in the nation's capital
where I live, Washington DC.
Which is also the only geographical entity
in the contiguous United States,
whose citizens must pay taxes
(air whooshing)
(car engine whirring)
and register for selective service,
without having political
representation in Congress.
Well, at least political representation
that can actually do something.
DC residents pay more taxes
than residents in 22 states,
and pay more money per capita
to the federal government
than any actual state.
Now, we are not the only ones.
Who else pays taxes
without representation?
Well, undocumented immigrants
pay about $7 billion a year
in taxes.
Inmates pay taxes,
and so do formerly incarcerated people,
even if their voting rights
have not been restored.
American children work and
pay sales tax and income tax,
but they lack the
representation of a vote.
And that's just the tip of the iceberg,
there's a whole bunch of
taxation without representation
in the United States.
And that's probably
because the Constitution
doesn't guarantee that right.
Americans hate taxes,
but they love shopping,
and a lot of people think
that they have a right
to enter a particular store,
or at least they have a right
to contract with other people,
the freedom to contract.
This guy believes he has
a Constitutional right
to eat at the Trump
Grill in New York City.
But here, the police officer contends
that a reservation is not
a Constitutional right.
- It's not a guarantee.
- They can't revoke my reservation.
It's not a Constitutional right.
- The protestor is in fact wrong
about his Constitutional right
to keep his dinner reservation.
But this is an interesting question,
(air whooshing)
do people
have a Constitutional right
to enter a store or a restaurant?
The Constitution is often
silent about most things.
So it shouldn't be surprising
that no one has an explicit reference
to where people are allowed to be.
But the 1980 US Supreme Court case
(air whooshing)
Pruneyard Shopping Center versus Robins,
said that the Constitution
does not give people an absolute right
to enter and remain on private property,
even if they intend to exercise
their first amendment right
to free expression.
So if this man wants to get
into a restaurant to protest,
he doesn't actually have a
Constitutional right to do so,
despite the first amendment.
But what about if the
city or state government
has imposed a vaccination
requirement to enter?
Does that violate the Constitution?
Well so far, the answer is no,
because not all unequal
treatment violates federal
or state laws.
The Civil Rights Act of 1964
explicitly prohibits restaurants
from refusing service to
customers based on race,
(air whooshing)
color, religion or national origin.
A restaurant can't refuse
service to black people
or white people or Muslims
or atheists, for example.
But when it comes to
other classes of people,
it's a complete tossup,
they can do what they want.
Restaurants and business
owners have argued
that they have a religious right
to refuse service to gay
and transgender people,
because of the owner's religious beliefs.
Now, the Supreme Court has yet
to definitively settle that issue
and it's going to be very
interesting to see what happens
with the Supreme Court
over the next few years
on this particular issue,
it's definitely going to come up.
But when a local regulation
prevents unvaccinated people
from entering a restaurant,
which is what happened with
the situation in New York City,
we're not talking about a protected
or quasi protected class of
people based on their race,
ethnicity, or gender,
that means a lower standard of review,
(air whooshing)
in other words,
rational basis review,
which basically no law ever fails.
So the bottom line is
that the Constitution
is not going to protect
your dinner reservation
if there is a specific enforceable law
that says you can't go inside.
Then there is a phrase
that I think everyone is familiar with,
(air whooshing)
the idea
that the criminal law presumes
that you are innocent until proven guilty.
Now, that idea that you
are presumed innocent
until proven guilty,
is one of the most significant
principles in American law.
The rights of criminal defendants
are very much part of the Constitution.
For example,
(paper rustling)
the Fifth Amendment
bars self-incrimination,
quote, "No person shall be
compelled in any criminal case
"to be a witness against himself."
(air whooshing)
This is known
as the right to remain silent.
The Sixth Amendment requires
(paper rustling)
that people be given a speedy
and impartial jury trial,
an attorney in criminal prosecutions
and establishes defendant's right
to confront adverse witnesses.
(air whooshing)
And the 14th Amendment
(paper rustling)
provides for due process of law.
However, the Constitution does not require
that a state prove that
someone committed a crime
beyond a reasonable doubt,
and the Constitution doesn't say
that you're innocent until proven guilty.
Now, I'm not saying that
the concept of innocent
until proven guilty is not important.
But the bigger point is that
not all fundamental rights
can be sourced directly to a line of text
in the Constitution.
Astute Legal Eagles probably already know
that many of our important
legal principles come
from English common law.
But the presumption of innocence
has a more complicated origin story.
It isn't found in any of the sources
we traditionally cite
for English common law,
like the Magna Carta, or the
English Bill of Rights of 1689,
or treatises by Coke and Blackstone.
In fact, this presumption comes
from Roman law and canon law,
which formed the common law of Europe.
And eventually, this principle
made it's way into common law
in a very roundabout way.
(air whooshing)
In Coffin
versus the United States,
the Supreme Court held that
the presumption of innocence
was a bedrock concept
in the American criminal justice system.
Then Justice White credited this
to an Irish jurist named Leonard McNally.
(air whooshing)
McNally was known as a zealous advocate
for Irish defendants who
were accused of treason.
And during McNally's lifetime,
the British system required two witnesses
to prove someone guilty of treason,
unless the accused was Irish,
in which case one witness was sufficient.
After McNally's death, the
English press found out
that despite his years of advocacy
for the presumption of Irish innocence,
McNally was, in fact, a double agent.
He represented Irish
revolutionaries in court,
but reported on their activities
to prosecutors for at least 26 years.
Despite McNally's dubious role
as a double agent for the government,
today the principle of
innocent until proven guilty
is fundamental to the
criminal justice system
in the United States,
despite it having no reference whatsoever
in the Constitution itself.
Now, that's just the tip
of the iceberg of things
that you're wrong about the Constitution.
But this video isn't over,
because there's another Legal Eagle video
about even more things that you're wrong
regarding the Constitution,
not you obviously, but
your friends probably.
Things like the filibuster
and the separation of church and state.
And this full length companion video
exists exclusively on Nebula,
because sadly, if I put it on YouTube,
it'd probably get demonetized
and there's no way that you'd ever see it.
But Nebula is different.
As you've probably heard by now,
Nebula is home to tons of
exclusive ad free content,
like my first full length
documentary, "Bad Law Words Good",
exclusive videos on the legal rights
that you definitely don't want to use,
anti slap laws and tons, tons more.
All of this exclusive
content is only on Nebula,
and you can get it for
free with Curiosity Stream.
Of course, the reason all of these videos
are exclusively available on Nebula,
is 'cause they probably just
wouldn't work on YouTube,
because of the way that the site works.
On the other hand,
Nebula is a different
platform without an algorithm
and without any ads,
because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment with content,
put things on there that we
just couldn't put on YouTube.
It's where I put all of my videos ad free
and usually extended
or with a completely
exclusive companion video.
I usually post my videos a
day or two early as well.
Nebula is creator owned and operated,
like with my friends Half As Interesting,
Marques Brownlee, RealLifeLore, Mike Boyd,
and tons of others.
There's new exclusive content
released multiple times every day.
And by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for iOS,
Android, Apple TV, Roku,
Fire TV, and Android TV.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream,
because they are the go-to
source for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity Stream.
And the best way to get access to Nebula
and all the incredible
content is definitely
through the amazing Curiosity
Stream Nebula bundle,
with it's current sales price
(bell chiming)
of less than $15 per year,
to get full access to both sites.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial,
it's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a
better deal in streaming,
where you get two streaming sites,
both with content you'll actually watch
and enjoy for less than $15 per year
at the current sales price.
But what's more, signing up
will actually help countless
independent educational creators
beyond just Legal Eagle.
So sign up by clicking on the button
that's right here on screen right now,
which will take you directly
to curiositystream.com/legaleagle,
or you can click on the link
that's in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive content
that you'll absolutely love.
So click on this link
that's on screen right now.
Or, you can click on this playlist
with all of my other YouTube videos.
So click here or I'll see you in court.